Daniel Magyar the sponsor of this next
segment is a personal trainer in weight
loss expert his new book weight loss
without Plateau is now a best-selling
book on three sectors of Amazon and he
joins us now congratulations on the book
Thank you very much I really appreciate
it best-selling book that's fantastic
what is inside this book what are we
going to find inside this book so during
the last 11 years in coaching people
and weight loss I've seen many people
plateau and there's nothing more
frustrating than working hard and
dieting hard and not getting results for
it so um it is important to understand
that Plateau is a natural process and
body actually wants to do it
so in this book I explain exactly the
reason why the body wants the plateau
and how to prevent it step-by-step guide
how to prevent the plateau a lot of it
is understanding human body's metabolism
and its ability to adapt to a low
calorie intake for a long period of time
so basically if you were in a calorie
deficit for a long period of time
there's something to their chairs it's
called metabolic adaptation
so the bottom line is someone's losing
some weight all of a sudden it just
stops and you're trying everything
trying everything this is the secret to
punching through exactly step-by-step
guide you look at you you're in great
physical shape I asked Daniel before we
started to say like what gym do you work
at you don't go to the gym where do you
work out not at home with resistance
bands I call the system called uh I
sorry I use the system called H3 and it
takes me about 20 to 25 minutes to
exercise and that's it that's all of my
resistance training for today because
you're an amazing shape what services do
you offer to people watching right now
you have weight loss personal training
so it is online coaching most of my
programs are online and I coach people
from point A to point B anywhere from
weight loss to muscle building to
sometimes bodybuilding competitions I
was looking at your Instagram too it's
full of tips and everything what is your
Instagram handle someone's watching
right now they want to get your website
they want to follow you on Instagram
because you are a great follower when it
comes to health tips and workout tips
what's the Instagram handle VM
underscore trainer and someone's
watching right now going into the
weekend what's what's one tip you can
give them when it comes to weight loss
or maybe someone wants to put on some
muscle what's that one little tip that
you can give them going into the weekend
cut the sugar alcohol and fried food one
more time cut the sugar alcohol sugar
alcohol fried foods that's the secret
right there cut it out and so no no
cocktails tonight after work is what
you're telling me so if you're trying to
beat your healthiest and then just move
too right get up your physical activity
a lot of physical activity resistant
training will be number one in high
intensity interval training of course
the hit cardio I would definitely
interpret that in a lifestyle and Daniel
real quick the book to weight loss
without Plateau we can get this on
Amazon absolutely and if you have some
kind of weight loss routine diet and
exercising it's not working this is the
secret to punch through and get those
extra results 100 beautiful Daniel thank
you so much for joining us Las Vegas now
we'll be right back